[Music]
Dave Ramsey here and this is the last
episode of our limited series real
estate the Ramsey Way today we're
talking about how to get rid of the ball
and chain too many homeowners are
dragging around the mortgage I know
paying off your mortgage early seems
impossible but it is completely doable
and people do it all the time but how
can you do it and why would you want to
put in the extra effort well stick
around to find out why paying off your
mortgage early will rev up your wealth
building
Journey Carl is next in St Louis hey
Carl what's
up hey how are you doing Dave so glad to
talk to you uh really excited on the
here with you thanks um so uh my wife
and I have kind of been in debt most of
our life and um boy I wish I found you
20 years ago and we paid off so much of
our debt um we paid off my car a little
quicker and after that we started
putting that car payment towards car and
we got sick and tired hair car and
started putting extra from savings to it
and we kept our savings at a set level
and put the extra against that car and I
was talking to my financial adviser
about a week ago and she's like oh my
gosh you just got one more month of this
just pay it off you're going to feel so
glad you did and so I did I paid off the
car and Bo it I feel excited so the only
debt we have remaining is our house and
uh we owe $45,000 on the house um we
have 35,000 in savings um and uh my
financial advisor is like oh man you
should just just put 25 of that against
your house you can pay that off in four
months then and just be done with it and
then build your savings back up and so I
was kind of like you know should I leave
more in savings should I just follow
that just just take a big 25,000 chunk
against savings just knock the house out
quick or should I just keep paying on
the house more and knock it out in about
nine months good for you wow well I like
your financial
advisor I thought you might I mentioned
your name to her so much of the time
yeah she uh she hates debt she hates
debt bad and and that's good because
your income once you get it all freed up
is she she knows the truth is going to
become your most uh powerful wealth
building tool when you're not giving it
all to someone else as a way of life and
you're beginning to experience the
emotions of these numbers in the last
few months it sounds like and it's very
exciting for you I'm I'm I'm proud of
you super ex okay so we teach a process
very that comes from the same principles
that she's leaning on that's why she and
I like each other I can tell and um so
baby step one is save $1,000 you've done
that okay baby step two is become debt
free other than the home and you've done
that baby step three is have an an
emergency fund of 3 to 6 months of
expenses
okay okay so I don't want your savings
below three months of household expenses
so if your household expenses are three
grand a month then we can go with her
plan well without a house payment it
would definitely be you have a house
payment you have a house payment still
yeah once that's knocked out with house
payment it's probably okay with house
payment monthly expenses is probably um
well probably pretty close to three okay
all right well no that's not true I
don't think it's that much I'd say it's
probably I mean the house payment is's
um um I make 145 my wife makes 48 right
about 48 she couple hundred a year okay
and so um uh
um yeah and if you take you said there's
35 in there right in your savings yes
and 40 on the H or 40 or 45 on the house
45 in the house okay so if we throw 25
at it leave 10 in there like she
suggests uh that means we have 20 left
on a
$200,000 household income and you're
done by Christmas then yeah it be done
by Christmas for sure yeah okay I don't
want you below
10 because are you okay with 10 um
borderline but but um I just want you to
gauge everything around you and be be
very wary because if you have a $115,000
event we got a problem dude and you make
200 Grand and that's silly
the other idea I had that I kind of
threw at my wife is um we were putting
what up you know the first thing was um
take our house payment put our two car
payments against it and then put the
exra we're putting from savings which
takes us to a house payment of 5100 a
month we're just kind of keep cranking
it up and so my other idea was every
month you know pay that and then pay an
additional five grand from savings and
kind of see how we feel as we're going
with that that would be okay too um yeah
I just don't want if I could establish
real comfortably what three was I mean
I'd be more comfortable with
15 I'd probably do it if it was
15 but people often call me and say I
have enough money in my savings account
to pay off my house today and it would
leave me with $1,000 left in my account
and I would tell them no and I I'm the
get out of debt
guy and I'm still telling them no
because I don't want you sitting there
with $1,000 at this stage of your
financial plan now at the beginning of
your financial plan when you're broke
and got a bunch of other debts and
everything else you're living on beans
and rice but this is more intentional
than it is intensity at your stage and
so I just want to be wise and careful
even though I'm as excited as you are to
get you out of debt so I'm guessing that
either way you're out of debt by
Christmas yeah it's going to be really
close if not I mean if we leave a little
bit more near it's going I think we're I
mean another way you could another way
you could work it
is you know another you know we're just
keep manipulating the numbers here here
but if you said okay let's just call it
3 to 6 months let's call it 20 grand
throw uh the rest of it at it and then
just start chunking on the house you're
still going to make it and if you don't
reach over and pull 10 out and take it
down to 10 for one
month yeah in December but just go you
know December I'm done as long as I
don't go below 10 in my savings but you
could if the math works the math works
on throwing it at the dead or it works
in throwing it in the account and then
pulling out of the account
so either way is fine um and uh but I I
would not stop are you saving for 401k I
would not stop
that absolutely yeah my wife puts about
11% in I'm putting about 7% in I'm
putting about another 8% into a uh ra IR
okay yeah you're getting you got the
right numbers and I wouldn't stop that
either so the the difference is only
whether it's uh Christmas or whether
it's March that's the only difference
and at and when you're 75 5 years old
that Daye won't matter I I like the
advice Dave and I'd actually be a little
bit more cautious with that savings
because if if it's me and I really want
to get this because it's just intensity
he sees the Finish Line how could you
make five to 10 grand extra that's what
I'm looking at I I I like that savings
posture I really do having that just in
case a big event happens because you're
talking about the difference between
three months so it's great advice I
certainly agree with you I would
personally I started getting a little
nervous to that going lower than 15
myself I was like yeah 10 or 15's got to
be your floor yeah for sure but I mean
you could just throw money you know
leave the saving sit like it sits and
throw money at the house and then when
you get within Striking Distance of
taking it down to 15 then do it in one
lick yeah then you're sitting on savings
the whole time while you're waiting to
do it and um that won't mess you up
either you'll still get there in exactly
the same period of time exactly and so
yeah it's a great place place to be
though Carl I love where your head's at
and I I like that you found a financial
adviser who's understood that getting
out of debt is the key to Building
Wealth because not having any payments
you know what you can do if you don't
have any payments anything you want I
mean it opens up the door baby it's uh
Americans live in such bondage that we
don't even know what it's like to be
free yeah I was getting ready to say if
you're new to the show and you're
listening and watching Carl is a great
example of where you can be you know he
started off by saying I wish I had found
you 20 years ago but they've they've
jumped into the pr and now he's looking
at the Finish Line he can't get there
fast enough it's a wonderful wonderful
place John is with us John's in Tampa hi
John how are you good sir how you doing
today better than I deserve what's up so
I have my wife in the background
listening she works at mortgages some
prior Marine Corps veteran we recently
sold our property that we owned and we
stood to gain
$175,000 from a property we own another
house
and our goal is should be debt free we
follow we follow your principles both go
to church and we owe about 100 uh about
$120,000 the property and $18,000 car
payment uh today when I finish work I'll
be going to pay off that car uh our
question uh collaboratively is do we do
a recast and put 50,000 60,000 down on
the house and pay it off in a year or do
we go out and pay it off out right our
savings we have about $30,000 in savings
so just sort of wanted to hear your
perspective so if you pay it off
outright how much is left in savings
there's about $35,000 so you wouldn't
have to touch
that um no as a as a whole there be okay
so why would you not just pay off your
house in your car today our biggest
worries is that if we're in a if we if
we find
ourselves um in in a recession or a a
housing market uh issue we wanted to
have money to potentially go and buy a
house on a cheap potentially a a not
refinance what do you call them a um a
foreclosure um we just want to hear your
perspective so you would not pay off
your house in order to maybe buy a
foreclosure if the housing market
tanks that that's our idea or our idea
is to have you know have that amount of
money set aside okay I would tell you
regardless of inflation and regardless
of recession that your best goal your
best process is to never buy a rental
property except with cash and to never
do that until your personal residence is
paid for and so that that set of
principles that I've used in my life and
for millions of others of people would
lead me to pay off your house and your
car today so pay off pay off the house
if it wasn't a rental property it was a
secondary it was a secondary I would be
debt free before I wrote any checks to
buy rental property and I would only pay
cash for rental property then so the
point being we're going to pay off this
other property we're going to pay off
your house you're house you're going to
pay off your car you're going to be 100%
debt free and have $35,000 left in the
bank you've got all of your income now
to start saving to buy a foreclosure
when the housing market goes down
someday I don't know when it's going to
go down uh not soon enough to change
this answer
okay so what you're saying is give you a
call back in a month and scream on the
air that we're debt free there you go
brother or next week if you want CU you
or or tomorrow if you want but yeah
because you're debt free pay off
everything that's what I would do listen
something's the uh the worry The Angst
that you have around the economy you're
watching the news too much number one
you need to turn the channel off but
number two uh the worry in the it's real
but there's no sense in just bathing in
the blood every night the blood of the
newscast and so uh
uh uh you know The Angst that I hear
what what you what you don't see coming
is that when you pay off all of this
stuff you're going to get peace yes and
you don't even realize that that's there
so because 100% we've done detailed
research 100% of the foreclosures occur
on a home with a
mortgage if you're wondering how paying
off your mortgage early would work for
your financial situation let us help you
crunch some numbers use our free
mortgage calculator to find out how
increasing your monthly payment can
shorten your mortgage term and help you
get rid of it as soon as possible just
go to the link in the show notes or
ramsy solutions.com
payoff calculator to check it out David
is calling from Saigon Vietnam I think
that's my first call from Saigon in 30
years David how are
you hi I'm good thanks how are you good
what are you doing in
Saigon um uh living abroad I've been
living uh my wife and I have been living
abroad for about 16 years uh but our
investments and properties are in the US
cool what do you do for a living and uh
International
Educator okay I teach teacher yeah I was
gonna say that sounded a lot like art
vanderlay importer exporter from
Seinfeld I've got a nice I actually have
a good friend whose brother lives in
Saigon that is in your business and I'm
wondering if you're him anyway yeah all
right go ahead brother how can we help
maybe I know him um well um okay we uh
we're we're big fans of the baby steps
we we've done them all we've done them
all except for one and I might get in
trouble from you on this one and that is
that we have two rental properties that
um that are turning um a profit and we
don't want to pay off the rest of the
mortgage because we feel like we're
making more having that money invested
in the
market so and I know you uh with your
baby steps you um highly recommend
paying off those mortgages or we
thinking why do that if we can make more
if that money is in the
market can you share your wisdom oh you
you want to know why I say to do that oh
I see okay and how much money do how
much money do you have in
Investments uh a little over a million
good for you well done how old are you
uh 57 excellent and how much are these
mortgages uh they're about 170 each so
340 knocks it out and that leaves you
with 660 in your investment if we use
that investment to pool to do that okay
is that
right uh yes okay and so really what
we're discussing is how much more you
would make on 340,000
over the interest on the houses okay now
here's the thing um I first approached
this through the lens of faith is was my
first approach because I have all the
letters and licenses after my name name
the academic crap that says I'm supposed
to know something about money but I went
broke so apparently I did something
wrong um and I and so I discovered uh
common sense and what the Bible says
about money and I can't find anywhere as
a Christian this is my my journey not
yours okay I can't find anywhere in the
Bible ever that says anything positive
about debt it's not a Salvation issue
you're not going to hell cuz you have
debt it's not a God loves you less if
you have debt it's all negative though
um the borrower is slave to the lender
and it goes on and on and on and on and
on all the negative references from that
so as as part of my faith walk I had to
say Okay God must know something or that
I don't understand about debt because I
was taught if you can borrow money at um
you know three four 5% on your mortgage
and you can invest it in a mutual fund
and make 10 or 12 then you're making
that spread that Arbitrage which is what
you're discussing in
correct yes exactly now as I've gone
forward what I've discovered is that the
vast majority of wealthy people that
we've
studied uh people of Faith or otherwise
have avoided debt and gotten out of debt
and uh and have stayed away from it and
I kind of had to stop and go why is that
and I find very few people now you're
not highly leveraged but I I find very
few people that are highly leveraged
that actually survive the people that
borrow money like crazy to buy rental
properties and do Airbnb and all this
crap uh they're all broke in 10 years I
went broke doing that within within 10
years and so you can't find someone
that's been doing that for 20 years and
survived one of these economic Cycles
takes their head off and so what that
means is that debt equals risk more debt
equals more risk and I think we can all
agree to that can
you uh yes you have little you have a
small amount of debt so it doesn't feel
like a lot of risk it's not as much risk
as if you had 3.4 million agre read
correct yeah yeah that's all I'm saying
more debt is more risk less R less debt
is less risk zero debt is approaching
zero risk and the only thing the only
math formula I have found that adjusts
for risk does not exist in the real
estate world it's only in the investment
world and we adjust for risk using the
math formula of a beta a beta is the
height of a uh if you do Peaks and
valleys of an investment it goes up and
down up and down up and down the the
differ in the Val the difference in the
peak and the valley is called a beta
your and it's your the Vol higher beta
is a higher volatility a a steeper
mountain and a more often cycle does
that make
sense yes and in the investment world we
use a beta the higher the beta the
higher the risk because the more
volatile it is and we use an inverse
relationship in the math meaning you
drop it under the denominator and
getting nerdy here but the that gives
you the ability to calculate risk into
the investment and measure a risky
investment against a not so risky
investment that has a lower beta and
you've you've neutralized for risk
therefore you can compare Them Apples to
Apples we don't enter risk into the
formula that you used to tell me you
wanted to keep your debt if we put risk
in that formula and you do have some
risk not as much as if you had 3.4
million but if we put a low beta in your
formula it starts to neutralize and do
away with all your spread the other
thing that happens is when you don't
have any payments you just straight up
sleep
better that's true and I've done and
I've done detailed research 100% of the
foreclosures occur on a house with a
mortgage and so I I would tell you this
let's do this you could try this if you
want to I would pay them both off and if
you hate it go get you another mortgage
later okay um okay fair enough can I ask
you another question a followup question
then so you should be scared to after
that long answer
yeah back in stats class y all that
money out we're going to pay we're going
to pay through the nose and taxes
pulling it all out of all of our um our
retirement Investments how old are you
so it's like oh you're 57 no I would not
take it out of retirement is it all in
retirement yeah this is all this you
don't have any money that's not in
retirement we have yeah we have some how
much we have um couple hundred well I'd
use that then
Tada you and you have a good income and
I would just no I'm not going to cash
out and pay penalties on your retirement
I was not suggesting that but because
that changes the formula now you may
have some capital gains on it and I I
would do that I have lived 100% debt
free since I went broke 30 something
years ago and I have had a wonderful
life I've made a lot of money I have a
lot of Investments and they're all paid
for and when crap happens like the
Island of Misfit Toys is misbehaving up
in Washington DC right now and they're
screwing up the whole freaking economy
I'm sitting here peaceful and slept
really good last night except that my
four-year-old grandson son put a plastic
snake under my pillow but other than
that I slept great last night that
really did happen good friend Cindy in
Baton Rouge hi Cindy how are
you hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's
up um we have my husband and I have
460,000 in a money market type account
and then we have 135,000 in
cash and we're to the point of saying
what do we do with this we're not making
any profit on most of that money and um
we took the 460 out of equities and
securities because we were losing a lot
of money in that and uh that money had
come from a home that we sold and
because we got an interest rate of 2.5
on a new home uh we went with the 2.5
and put the 460 into Securities and
equities and uh didn't want to lose it
beyond what we put in there so put it in
a money market par what do you owe on
your
home 36 6K
okay
um from 30 years of coaching people how
to become wealthy and from doing uh a
study of 10,000 millionaires these are
the two sources for my
data that tells me the shortest distance
between where you are and wealth is two
things is a um consistently funded 401K
Roth IRA in good growth stock mutual
funds over a long period of time that
becomes some money and a paid for house
our last debt-free scream was a
$600,000 uh paid for house and $800,000
in their 401k or reverse I forget which
but it was $1.4 Million net worth and it
was just a few moments ago while you
were on hold you heard
it yes okay so that is the typical path
that we see that is the most often used
by people who become millionaires now
where does that take us in your
situation it's it says I would pay off
my house
today because here's what you ended up
doing it wasn't the start of your plan
but the net result of your plan is you
borrowed money at
2.35% and invested it at a half a
percent right yes sir we were I know
that wasn't where you that wasn't what
you set out to do but that's where you
ended up isn't
it it is I pay off my house today
today by close of business
today write a
check
okay okay and now you don't have any
house payment anymore how's that
feel awesome because I want to retire
yeah and now you got $200,000 in cash
that we got to do something better than
a stupid money market account with you
need an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses for your short-term
emergencies and um I mean you know let's
call that 50 Grand at your house for the
fun of it you've still got 150,000 that
you need to do something with other than
a stupid butt savings account now if you
put it into some kind of a mix with a
stock broker and you were losing money I
get that if you put it into good mutual
funds and the overall economy slowed
down like it is right now and the value
went down then you didn't have somebody
good in your corner to coach you and say
hey the only person gets hurt on a
roller coaster is those that jump off in
the middle of the ride which is exactly
what you did
now were you invested in single
stocks no you're in mutual
funds very Diversified in mutual
funds some of them were in mutual funds
okay well what I would do is sit down
with a good investment broker and here's
what you're looking for this time um and
uh you're looking for someone with a
heart of a teacher that teaches you the
history of the mutual fund that you're
putting them money into okay I'll give
you an example I own one that's over 80
years old in the 80 years it's been open
fewer than 15 of the those 80 years has
have been a down year so if we happen to
have a down year and I know
that I know that not my broker knows
that but I know that then I'm not
freaking out it's kind of like the house
that you own in Baton Rouge if it went
down in value this year you wouldn't
freak out because generally speaking
homes in the neighborhood you live in
for the past 40 years have gone up in
value or
agreed agreed so you wouldn't freak out
on one down year and bail out that's
just like that mutual fund I'm
describing I'm not going to freak out in
one down year and bail out but that's
all knowledge on your part rather than
depending on someone else to tell you
what to do and then you get scared
because you watch the news and you never
take Financial advice from the
news if the commercial breaks where
you're watching TV are walk-in bathtubs
gold commercials and reverse mortgages
and Snuggies that tells you you don't
want to take Financial advice
there that's just a bad plan and
so here's me looking at you fox but
anyway yeah so there you go but the uh
Fox Business right but I love them
they're wonderful but the commercials
are comical Saturday Night Live hard I
can't hold it in you're not saying
walking bathtubs are a bad idea just the
investment advice I'm just saying if
this is where you get your investment
advice when the commercial breaks are
walk-in bathtubs and Snuggies then you
know you're not getting good this is
this is a bad place
oh oh that was perfect I'm sorry that
just got me that was like the church
giggle I couldn't hold it any longer
we've all sat and watched them at the
commercial I know exact I know exactly
what you're talking about yeah the and
and we're on there giving Financial
advice so what do we know but anyway the
uh uh but you know you really need to
sit with a good broker who has the heart
of a teacher go to ramsy solutions.com
click on smartvestor sit down with them
interview them and what you're looking
for here is is a type of wisdom not
intellect there's a difference there's a
lot of very very intellectual
ignoramuses out there and that's not in
the world in in general that's not what
you're looking for you're looking for
common sense wisdom that says I bought a
mutual fund that for 80 years has only
had less than 15 down years so we're
having a down year I don't need to
panic and that you learn that you
internalize that you emotionally swallow
that and then it becomes part of your
plan and so in that situation then you
invest in good mutual funds in your
401ks and your Roth IRAs and those kinds
of things and you get your house paid
for and that's what I'm going to do with
your 150 unless you've got other debts
and then I'm going to clean that up too
so I want you debt free 100% And
investing in good growth stock mutual
funds that is a the shortest P that have
long track records that are comfortable
to you and that you understand what's
going on you didn't do it cuz I said do
it or because some goob at a financial
office said do it it's because you
learned and your knowledge allows you to
sleep at
night you know Ken that's the difference
between tossing and turning at night
when the stock market's down yeah is
whether you made the decision based on
knowledge you had or knowledge someone
else had yeah well it's true I mean you
for you years I mean before I even
started working with you this idea the
roller coaster analogy that you've given
and it's really true when you look at
the data uh if you look over the last 30
years you just got to stay calm and ride
this thing out I just don't freak out
when I see the stock market dip you know
I say hey we keep investing that's an
opportunity it's going to come back and
and you're right knowledge uh is what
gives us tremendous confidence and
confidence the peace yeah and once you
really understand that folks about the
stock market then when it goes down you
kind of go like it's on sale yeah we're
getting bargain right now it's a bargain
time y this is a time to buy well we
don't really do that either cuz I'm not
going to tell you to time the market I'm
just going to tell you steady invest
steady invest that's all I have done I
have been tempted at times when the
market is down to time it yeah I really
really wish in 2008 when the stock
market was crashing and the worldse
coming to an end and it went from 13,000
to 6,500 I really wish I had put an
extra million dollars in yeah because I
mean the Dow's sitting at what X of that
that million wow today would be worth 6
million wow because it D you know 30,000
over 30,000 right so um yeah there you
go I mean that's 5x 5x of that be worth
$5 million now ultimately I did have
money in there and it's worth 5x but if
you could have timed the market and
bought at the lowest possible time we've
seen in decades then that would have
been the time to do it but who knew when
the bottom
was here's the deal every dollar you add
to your mortgage payment puts a bigger
dent in your principal balance if you
add even one extra payment every year
you'll knock years off the term of your
mortgage plus save thousands of dollars
in interest listen I'm telling you when
the bank doesn't own your house and you
step into the backyard the grass feels
different under your feet because it's
all yours all right guys thanks for
listening to our exclusive real estate
series it's been a blast and I hope you
enjoyed it as much as I have make sure
to let us know what you thought of it
and share this series with the people in
your life getting ready to buy or sell a
home